I don't know if you're done yet but I'm
gonna give you a nudge along the way
you're not and also they help you out
with some of the hydro just to make sure
your numbers are correct okay so what's
going on firstly this slide here okay
very simple but don't neglect it okay
the primary reason why is because when
you're going from words to equations
where the two questions okay I find it a
lot easier to make problems into each of
these problems where I don't have these
lines okay because this
I'm literally reading off the questions
okay but this is from P 2 a is double
the distance from P to be okay sometimes
you put two on the wrong side and all
the algebra will come out but you just
have the wrong walkers okay so just be
careful so that's why my two appears
here and worth highlighting is the two
doesn't say a - okay get some bright
colors and point to this ball okay
because again one of the challenges with
this kind of topic it is that everything
will look ok
and you won't work out till later
there's dramatic polls and maybe you
won't work it out because the numbers
look ok and now when you get down to
here so every time that you stop okay
in a sense because I didn't say it right
um I didn't ask I didn't specify what
form the equation should be now question
if they don't specify what form would
you default to probably general because
general like the general play is just
you know not an area that's the most so
remember for each different kind of
function or relation actually you've got
it to me general form so for a straight
line what's the general yeah everything
on the one side equals to see you
right just to be nitpicky your AB&C
should for you all know this and you're
actually positive okay for parabola
what's the Jetta for all of the terms
rank all the coefficients match the
straight line but instead you've got
these powers coming down okay why don't
you know phones you know okay
I wind I'm right what I got him we want
to have a four which makes the the
geometric features of the circle obvious
namely it's set up and it's radius okay
so you could put it you might have seen
this fall we've got X minus K squared
minus H squared I don't know why they
can H you know what have you seen what I
then I don't know I thought to save me
this is a ratio this these are at
general sorts of equations right which
is this closest to as a circle right key
see it's got all the bits for the circle
just has been factorize nice and neatly
okay so let's do that
factorize you requires that most archaic
of skills I'm completing the square okay
maybe you forgot how to do this we're
solving quadratics you might for why we
have to committee square it's a very
inefficient way of doing things
you can factorize or you can use the
formula right they're both better that
if you complete a sweater faster
the reason why we kept teaching here is
because it is just because it sounds all
right so let's do it
to complete the sweat the first thing
you want to do is get all of your arm
square terms your x squared and your Y
squared
you want them to be wanting it right so
you want them to not be three month one
okay so I'm going to divide everything
through by 3 that's going to give me x
squared plus this weird-looking fraction
okay is that you contend with that so
far now what I'll do just to make it
easier for my brain is to match up the
parts that relate to each other okay
just so it makes it easy to beat back a
lot of that I may as well also take is
10 over 3 and move it to the other side
why eventually this is 10 over 3 or
negative 10 right it's going to become a
part of this R squared
I don't want it over here so I'm gonna
yeah how do I complete the square there
are two steps to it right I'm adding
stuff to these two different things to
make them to swear that's why it's gone
completely scram right what do I have to
add look at this
which number on my paying attention to
the ten over three right you got it
two things you've got a harbor and then
you've got a square
okay cover square it and that'll tell
you what you have to add okay so when I
harvest I get five ten six five and
three okay and then I have to square
that which gives me twenty five over
nine okay now since I added 25 100 here
to keep it balanced after a decoder - so
- okay now conveniently because I chose
some okay know this right it's the same
thing here even though it's negative I
have it I'll get that you do follow
3-burner spirit that comes out to wash
okay so if this and another one so I'm
just going to multiply this place now
what does that give us now that I get is
25 on nine right add it onto both of
these back in say x squared + 10 on 3x +
25 online this thing is a square knife
in fact ERISA and Oh tell me the setup
okay this is also square
someone tell me what the radius where
it's gonna be what value do we get some
of me fashion 20 I also need to actually
fish baptizing these so I can get into
this form okay so what am I gonna do
remember when we carved it and then
square it right well this is going to be
X plus the hard part right can when you
square it that's what so I just
remembered that the violins three before
is red okay they might set up you can
read it off there and I guess here how
would you rewrite that well you want to
put that as swear this right so my
radius is the square root of Cleveland
and that's a bit messy but you can work
out what that's going to look like to
the circle so that's interesting right
just by doubling this distance you went
from our line to a circle